okay time is of the s's now so you've
got to get that and yourself safely down
to me I'm at the base of the cliff
so use those improvised talents remember
that Italian hitch lower it down and
then lower yourself okay copy that
it's a big army looking duffel type bag
I think uh like a kit bag of some sort
it's heavy it's heavy
spread them out wide
sync them in
yeah it's pretty loose grounds this
makes me nervous
like
these talents can hopefully dig in a bit
deeper
give me a better chance of
I'm holding my body weight
finish
okay
this is annoying me what am I doing
wrong here
you know it's hard remembering that
Italian hitch when you're tired and cold
and hungry
come on Benedict you can do this
there we go
looks good
I
think hey whoa two three
there we go
here comes the bag
inside the bag
is one of the ways we're going to get
out of here I've got a few little
surprises for him yet there you go
perfect yeah yeah keep it coming keep it
coming almost there
package received good job okay so secure
that line tie that same Italian hitch
into yourself
and then lower yourself copy that we'll
do
so this goes in the middle yeah okay
maybe that's good
there we go
feet wide
soft
slow as you go don't put your hand too
far up
in the back of your mind that there are
just these pieces of metal in quite
loose sod really
it's very easy to push into which makes
you suspect you might be very easy to
push out of them
okay
okay Benedict's on his way
hope you figured out that Italian hitch
slippery cold
it's also a lot of fun
foreign
look at that
[Music]
thank you